let's get to the topic of you selling  everything  why'd you do that the reason i sold was  because i was really afraid of the  chinese housing market their largest  housing firm went bankrupt and that's  scary because in china that's like their  way to invest if like you have extra  money like that's the only way you can  invest in china because you can't go  into the stock market because it's owned  by like the state i mean even your house  is on by this year you know you can't  buy a house yeah it's like you lease it  from the states yeah you buy nine you  buy the rights for 99 years  they're the ones that don't just yeah  actually have their idea weird right  yeah so if you invest in china you're  always investing in real estate and  their main real estate company like went  under i was afraid of like some horrible  chain reaction no that's what i was  afraid no yeah